you must be mr. Benjamin hi can you tell
me about some of your previous coins
Trevor would be my first client my child
has a unique sense of humor you know
could you call the make-a-wish
Foundation and tell me what a [ __ ]
okay Barry
he wakes at the same time every day you
watch his TV at the same time every day
he eats at the same time every day two
waffles one sausage did you arrange
these look like large testicles and a
small penis you know did you bring the
divorce papers I'm not ready Jimmy it's
been two and a half years what's the
magic number will you wake up and you're
finally ready what's the thing you want
to do most fewer totally fine this is a
map of your country's lamest roadside
attractions the world's deepest pin
world's biggest bovine what makes you
think I will let you take my son on a
road trip I won't let anything happen to
yourself
get rid of Slim Jim bite it to the James
now what they say in your country
check it out man the world's biggest
bovine you good yeah yeah do
we've arrived either my name's Ben are
you a bird I'm not a perfect that's
exactly what a partner would say I'm dot
so two parents got room for one life
I want to see my father he left me I was
three
hi we need Bob tell him it's Trevor and
if that doesn't jog his memory stays in
a wheelchair if that is jog his memory
sees your son and if that doesn't jog
his memory say you're an enormous dick I
can't have you getting too close to
Trevor I can't have you making promises
you can't keep
are you asking me on a date yes I am
you know my father okay I help you oh
you know this is not about me it's about
years
I'm gonna call the make-a-wish
Foundation now get Katy Perry to meet us
at a motel
what side he want her to sing while
she's doing you fireworks
you